مرحبا بكم من جديد نيويورك بانتظار
احتماليه اي وجه المدعي العام
براج اتهاما للرئيسي الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب خاصه انه لم يحدث شيء مما
قاله الرئيس السابق عن ان السلطات
الامريكيه ستوقفه خلال اربع وعشرين ساعه
مضت ومع انتظار قرار المدعي العام تنتشر
حواجز الشرطه امام برج ترامب ومحكمه
منهاتن في ظل حشد غير كبير لمؤيديه وفق
الوكاله الفرنسيه للانباء فيما تتوقع
وسائل اعلام امريكيه بان هيئه المحلفين
الكبرى يمكن ان تصوت مساءا خلال الساعات
القادمه اذا لصالح وضع لائحه اتهام الا ان
اعلان المدعي العام قال ان لائحه اتهام ضد
ترامب قد يستغرق حتى الاسبوع المقبل حينها
سيلزم او سيلزم الرئيس السابق بالاجابه
امام القضاء بشان دفع مبلغ 130 الف دولار
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه ستورمي دانييلز
المتهمه او المتهم انه اقام معها علاقه
خارجه اطار الزواج في عام فوزه
بالانتخابات الامريكيه بالمقابل ندد
الملياردير ترامب بما وصفها بحمله اضطهاد
يقودها الديمقراطيون في الوقت الذي بائت
فيه دعوته للاحتجاج بالفشل وفقا لوسائل
اعلام امريكي
فريق حمله ترامب للانتخابات الرئاسيه
للعام 2024 ترامب لم يرتكب اي جريمه
متحدث باسم الشرطه استعداد شرطه نيويورك
ثابت ولجميع الاحتمالات
فيما قالت اللجنه القضائيه بمجلس النواب
في رساله لمدعي عامه ان قرار المقاضاه تم
لدوافع سياسيه
اما شبكه سي بي اس الامريكيه فاشارت الى
ان التهديدات وخطابات العنف على الانترنت
ترتفع من جهتها نشرت يو اس اي تودي ان
ترامب واجهه اربعه الاف وخمسه وتسعين دعوه
قضائيه في ثلاثه عقود
ونتابع مباشره منا واشنطن مع بشار جرار
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن اسامه سيبلاني
ناشر جريده صدى الوطن مرحبا بكم ضيفي
الكريمين سيد بشار ابداء معك اذا الثلاثاء
يمضي ولم يعتقل ترامب كما كان يصور وقام
بحشد مناصريه اذا هل الموضوع مفتعل حتى
يستغل له ترامب سياسيا في حملته لرئاسه
عزيزي هو مفعل ولكن من الجانب الاخر مر
الثلاثاء ومره الاربعاء ايضا
وقبل اقل من ساعتين اعلنت هيئه المحلفين
بانها الغت اجتماع اليوم الذي كان من
المفترض ان يصدر عنه شيء يفيد باليه توجيه
الاتهام الان ما يجري هو بالفعل انه قام
بفعل استباقي هو متميز دائما الرئيس ولكن
ماذا قصدها بانه مفتعل من الطرف الاخر
تقصد من مدعي عاما هاتا نعم والحزب
الديمقراطي
تحديد هو هذا الم كل عام وانتخب انتخابا
هو قريب من يسار الحزب الديمقراطي ليس فقط
الديمقراطي
والذي قام به اعتبر محاوله لتحريك ملف
قديم واكثر ما يقال به بانه بمعنى هذه
جنحه لا يحاولون مهما استطاعوا وليست
جنايه يعني نعم نعم بمعنى انه تحرك خاطئ
هنا من الحزب الديمقراطي ام لا بالفعل
وهذا ما اربكهم
هو استباق استباق اعلامي اربكهم قانونيه
وسياسيا عندما قال بانه هذه التسريبات
الغير قانونيه التي تفيد انني ربما اتعرض
الاعتقاد يوم الثلاثاء ماذا فعل حرك
القاعده في الحزب الجمهوري وخاصه اليمين
المحافظ ووجهها رساله الان لا ستعي جمهوري
التقاعس فيها موجهه وصلت الفكره نعم استاذ
اسامه ما رايك فيما ذهب اليه الاستاذ بشار
انه
القصه مفتعله قصه اعتقال ترامب ولكنها من
مناوئيه في الحزب الديمقراطي ولكنه هو عرف
جيدا كيف يوظفها لصالحه وكيف يحشد مؤيديه
وكان يمكن ان يستفيد منها اكثر لو كان
بالفعل جرى اعتقاله فعليا ما رايك
كل هذه الاحداث تحصل على خلفيه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه هنالك استطلاعات للراي
تضع
في مقدمه المرشحين من حزب الجمهوري كما
هنالك استطلاعات للراي تقول بانها تفيد
بان دانل ترامب يتقدم على الرئيس جو بايدن
حاليا لذلك كل ما فعله الحزب جمهوري او
الحزب الديمقراطي من اجل ردع ترامب من
الترشح لم ينهي عن هذا الترشح وربما وربما
يكون وسيكون اعتقد بانه هو المرشح
الجمهوري اليوم المتقدم وربما يكون في عام
2024 المرشح الجمهوري لذلك يلجا الحزب
الديمقراطي بكل ادواته لمنع ترامب من
الترشح او لعرقله ترشحه في هذا المرحله
وربما تكون المساله الوحيده التي يمكن
الاعتماد عليها هي رفع دعوى قضائيه ضد
ترامب وارباكه
العمل السياسي وهنا تكمن الخطا يكمن الخطا
الكبير الذي يرتكبه الحزب الديمقراطي لانه
يعطي المزيد من الدعم والمزيد من الزخم
الى حمله ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري وربما
داخل
المحيدين في الناخبين للامريكيين طيب يبدو
انكما ضيفي الكريمين اتفقتما على هذه
النقطه على انه هي
تحرك من الحزب الديمقراطي ولكنه يخدم
ترامب بشكل او باخر في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله 2024 ولكن السؤال هنا
استاذ بشار اسالك في واشنطن هل
فعلا سيستفيد ترامب من هذا الامر لانه
بالنهايه اذا ما اعتقل
وتم توجيه تهمه جنائيه له فانه وبالتالي
سيحرم من الترشح لانتخابات 2024 التي لم
تحسن بعد لانه لديه منافسين ايضا من الحزب
الجمهوري ام لا بالفعل هو استفاد استفاد ج
مهوريه الحزب
الجمهور الذي يتقدم بشكل دافئ مرشح
المنافس نعم
تماما وفي مقابل اجراها اجرتها فقص نيوز
بعد سانتوس قال صراحه بان ما تعرض له
ترامب هو اضطهاد سياسي وبان الحزب
الجمهوري لن يقبل بهذا الامر ولا
الامريكيين تقبلون بما يتعلق له رئيس سابق
ومرشح قادم وهنا الخطوره يا عزيزي ايضا في
قواعد الحزب الجمهوري الان تبين صحه ما
كان يطرح دائما بانه يتعرض لحمله غير
مسبوقه لم يتعرض لها ابدا اي رئيس في
تاريخ الولايات المتحده من هذه نظريه صيد
الناس تتعاطف مع المظلوم يعني
المعسكر الاخر وهو جد اندال هي الاصوات
المستقله والمتارجحه
اضطهاد سياسي وهذا امر خط احمر هذا
الامريكي نعم استاذ اسامه سيبلاني كيف
يتعاطف الامريكيون مع رئيس سابق يعني حتى
ولو لم تثبت عليه التهمه ولكنه اقام علاقه
مع ممثله اباحيه خارج اطار الزواج
صحيح ولكن هنالك تجارب اخرى في الحزب
الديمقراطي
وتعود الى كلينتا الذي كانت له فضيحه في
البيت الابيض عندما كان في البيت الابيض
وكان متزوجا ايضا طبعا القضيه يعني فيها
فيها دموع من وان اسال سؤال لانه خاصه انه
بالحزب الجمهوري هناك فئه كبيره من
المحافظين يعني من من المتدينين دعنا نقول
الامريكيين المحافظين
هذه قضيه قضيه ترامب بغض النظر عن عن رايي
في ترامب انا لا اؤيد ترامب ولكن القضيه
التي رفعها رفعها الحزب الديمقراطي او
المناصرين للحزب الديمقراطي على قضيه
سخيفه جدا عند المجتمع الامريكي المجتمع
الامريكي اليوم مخصوم ومخصوم عموديا
ومخصوم بشكل قوي جدا وربما هذه التجاذب كل
قضيه تطفو على السطح اليوم هي سياسيه حتى
لو كانت صغيره يعني من الفلافل يشتبك
عليها الحزب الجمهوري والحزب الديمقراطي
الاشتباك يوم قوي جدا وبالتالي لا يمكن
فصل ترامب عن هذه القضايا التي هو الذي
قادها عندما اصبح رئيسا للبلاد وعندما
ترشح رئاسه هنالك انقسام مالكي وكل شيء
يستثمر في السياسه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لذلك هذه القضيه رغم انها سخيفه
جدا التي يقاضى عليها ترامب
مثل ما تفضلتم في بدايه اللقاء وقلتم على
مدى ثلاثه عقود يعني عنده اختصاص الزلامه
في الذهاب الى الفضائح
او من الازمات نعم لانه شهدنا وايضا في
مساله الوثائق ايضا يعني هو احسن كذلك
استغلالها مع انه كانت ستهدد مسار السياسي
نعم
اليوم هي قضيه جيمس يقضيه يسموها في في
الاطار الصفر صفر
يعني المدني وليس الجنائي هي في نيويورك
ايضا
بانه كذب
وضخم
بيته في في منهات وبالتالي لاجل القبض
عليه مبلغ من الاموال ربما يفوق ثلاثه
اضعاف ثمنه يعني كل القضايا التي ينبشها
في القبور نفس القبور عند الحزب
الديمقراطي لن يفيد الحزب هنا هنا اسالك
نعم السيد بشار هل هذا النبش في القبور
كما وصفه ضيفي من ميشيغان
يفيد ترامب دوما يزيد من شعبيته يخدمه في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله ام لا يمكن
يعني في واحده من هذا
ينبشوا له قصه من هذه القصص يمكن فعلا ان
تطيح به وتنهي مشوار السياسي
صهيب نفس القبور متاح دائما عند الحزب
الديمقراطي بيبقى في ذلك الناخبين هناك
كثير من الاصوات الميتين الذين صوتوا في
هذه الانتخابات والانتخابات السابقه ايضا
المشكله الان ان حتى طبعا كما يدعي ترامب
يعني تزوير الانتخابات نعم
من الفوضى تزويرا ولكن مره اخرى القضيه
عزيزي
الان الكل يعلم انا لن تاتي باي شيء فهي
والحزب الجمهوري حتى الان كما قالت الان
سيجلب اظن براج سيجلبه الى مجلس النواب
الامريكي ويحقق معه ذلك هذا الموضوع قلب
المجني يا عزيزي صهيب الان هو احتراف
سياسي اعلامي يخوض فيه ليست قطرا فقط
وانما الكثير من الوطنيين الامريكيين هذه
المعركه امام الطهاره السياسي البعض يقول
علانيه الرئيس يقول امريكا اصبحت دوله
عالم ثالث بل اسوا في هذه الاستاذ اسامه
سبلاني هل انتهى الموضوع بالنسبه لترامب
استفاد منه وانتهى الامر وظهر بان لديه
مؤيدين
وبانه اذا اعتقل كما قال ايلون ماسك لاحدى
تغريداته اذا اعتقل دونالد ترامب فانه
سيربح باكتساح الانتخابات القادمه هل
انتهى الموضوع ام انه يمكن في القضاء يعني
اذا اثبت انه دفعه 130 الف دولار
[موسيقى]
دانييلز اسم الممثله هذه
نعم اذا ما ثبت هذا بانه
جنحه او جنايه فانه ممكن ان لا ينتهي
الموضوع هنا
اعتقد بانه متحده الامريكيه تعيش مخاض
سياسي وربما تكون حرب اهليه بارده
اي نوع من
الاندفاع الديمقراطيه خارج الحدود التي
يمكن ان يقبلها الحزب الجمهوري يمكن ان
تشعل فتيل
حرب اهليه داخليه اعتقد بانه كلنا نجزم
بان الحزب الديمقراطي والحزب جمهوري اليوم
يقفون على تناس يعني مع بعضهم البعض وانا
اعتقد بانه سيخرج داره ترامب منتصرا من
هذه
للاسف يعني انا لست من المؤيدين لدعم
ترامب ولكن الحقيقه الحقيقه بان الحزب
الحزب الديمقراطي او ربما الليبراليين في
الحزب الديمقراطي يعني يضعونه دونالد
ترامب ويكتشفون ويدفعون بدوله رب الى
الامام غير يعني غير انهم يريدون غير
ارادتهم ولكن بفعلهم
يدعمون دانالد ترامب بطريقه غير مباشره
وربما يعمقون الخلاف قبل الانتخابات هلا
ماذا سيحصل لا نعرف لانه في امريكا هنالك
محاكم محليه وهنالك محاكم استئناف في
المحل في المحليات يعني وربما في استئناف
في على مستوى الفيدرالي وهنالك
الارض في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
فالقضيه هي في بدايتها طيب بسرعه لو سمحت
ضيفي استاذ بشار ماروك فيما تخوف منه
الاستاذ اسامه ان هناك حرب اهليه بارده في
امريكا بالنظر الى حجم الاستقطاب الحاصل
الان مره اخرى مع انصار ترامب وشاهدنا ما
حصل في احداث الكابيتول بعد قوله انه لن
يعترف بفوز جو بايدن وقتها اتفق تماما حرب
بارده وداخليه لان الانقسام في الحسبين
والانقسام اكثر الخوف من ظهور حزب ثالث
الان هناك خيار رد ترامب فيما لو تعذر
الحصول على الاغلبيه في الحزب الجمهوري
وهذا شبه مستحيل بانه سيترشح بنفسه وحتى
اسم الحزب
طرح بانه سيكون الحزب الثالث هناك بالفعل
حرب بارده لان الخلاف اي امريكا نريد نريد
امريكا اباء الاوائل التي انا اؤمن بها
وهاجرت اليها ام امريكا يريدون تغييرها
بكل شيء
حتى اجتماعيه مسلم بها قضايا تتعلق فيه
الكومنسانس من هو الرجل ومن هي المراه وما
هي الاسره نعم شكرا جزيلا لكم ضيفي
الكريمين بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من واشنطن العاصمه
سيبلاني ناشر جريده صدى الوطن